qué monarquía deja y saber segundo
y en una monarquía muy distinta a la que
ella
a la que le cayó en sus manos en 1952
cuando falleció y fue de su país de su
padre
una monarquía y un mundo muy distinto un
reino unido muy distinto isabel segunda
asumió el trono cuando todavía el reino
unido era el imperio británico
y durante su reinado se dio la
independencia de la mayoría de los
estados que formaban las regiones que
luego pasaron a ser estados que formaban
el imperio británico y que se unieron en
la commonwealth esta unión de países
miembros antiguos miembros del imperio
británico que tiene como presidente al
rey de inglaterra actualmente y que
realmente fue una creación de isabel
segunda los países del imperio shiva
independizando e iban permaneciendo en
esta comunidad de naciones
presidida por por la reina y de la cual
la reina llegó a ser jefe de estado de
varios de sus países de muchos de sus
países y el rey carlos lo es actualmente
de 14
la sociedad británica es completamente
distinta hacia una sociedad
multicultural multirreligiosa
multirracial cosa que no lo era al
inicio de su reinado
y su familia pues tenía unas
características realmente especiales al
inicio de su reinado las características
más similares a las del siglo 19 que no
a las del siglo 20 y esas
características de su familia han ido
cambiando a lo largo de esos 70 años de
reinado recuerden ustedes que al
principio de su reinado a la corte no
podían acudir los divorciados
imagínense la evolución que ha tenido la
corte británica y la mentalidad de la
misma familia real a lo largo de estos
70 70 años de reinado una evolución
enorme como el mundo una de las grandes
virtudes de la monarquía es la
adaptación a los tiempos y así lo ha
hecho y ser el segunda es su familia
a lo largo de estos años una
modernización de los tiempos que estuvo
muy a la altura y saber segunda verdad
completamente
asesorada por su marido porque su marido
no era un hombre muy moderno que estaba
también muy en contacto con la realidad
social política
cultural del mismo reino unido pero
también de europa
pues entre los dos creo que hicieron un
buen tándem para hacer los cambios que
hicieran posible la puesta al día la
actualización de las formas de los modos
de la mentalidad de la familia real
británica de la corona británica a los
nuevos tiempos recuerden que la reina
isabel hizo miembros de diversas órdenes
de caballería órdenes de premiarles a
los beatles los rolling stones oval
todas las grandes estrellas del cine del
teatro y de la música británicos de los
últimos 60 años eso al inicio de su
reinado era una cosa
bueno que que no era no era una cosa
posible y esa evolución la hicieron
posible y ser el segundo y su esposo
felipe
hablaba usted de la conformación de la
commonwealth nou que en el cual bueno
isabel segunda tuvo un rol clave en
aquella época en la que sea precisamente
asumía el trono y reino unido- ingresaba
en este período de descolonización que a
diferencia de muchos otros países tuvo
esto no que fue la commonwealth y
mantener vínculos no y sobre todo
influencia en todos estos países que
conforman la comunidad esto fue
realmente uno de los grandes hitos no de
su reinado fue uno de los grandes hitos
de su reinado esa transición de colonias
a miembros estados de la comunidad de
naciones británicas no sin dificultades
obviamente hay que hay que estudiar leer
las independencias de cada uno de sus
estados para ver qué es esos procesos de
independencia no fueron fáciles pero
isabel segunda hizo posible que a partir
de la independencia
esos países volvieran a tener unas
relaciones privilegiadas con el reino
unido con su antigua metrópolis
y luego tuvieran unas relaciones
especiales entre todos ellos
quizás el segundo tenía muchísimo cariño
por esa esa labor que a lo largo de su
reinado realizó y tuvo una relación
privilegiada con imagínense todos los
primeros ministros o presidentes de los
reyes de todos estos países a lo largo
de 70 años es impresionante y la tuvo
esa especial relación